A gente traz agora uma entrevista exclusiva com o candidato à presidência da República pelo Partido Liberal, o senador Flávio Bolsonaro.
A conversa foi gravada na manhã desse domingo em São Paulo.
Ajuste fiscal, combate à ação dos narcotraficantes, escolha de ministro do Supremo Tribunal Federal e a possibilidade de retornar o pai, o ex-presidente Jair Bolsonaro, ministro de seu governo.
Foram alguns dos temas abordados pela âncora do Jornal da Record, Mariana Godoy.
Vamos conferir.
O Domingo Espetacular recebe o senador Flávio Bolsonaro.
Estamos ouvindo os candidatos à presidência da República.
Senador, muito obrigada por nos dar essa entrevista em pleno domingo.
Eu que agradeço o convite, Mariana, agradeço a Record pelo espaço.
Que possamos falar muito de futuro no nosso Brasil.
Vamos falar de futuro, mas vamos começar falando sobre a sua relação com o ex-banqueiro Daniel Vorcaro,
porque o senhor pediu 61 milhões e depois surgiram até tratativas que chegavam a 134 milhões a Daniel Vorcaro do Banco Master,
para financiar o Dark Horse, que é a cinebiografia do seu pai.
O Vorcaro está preso, acusado de fraudes bilionárias, no caso do Banco Master.
E quando cobrado sobre a prestação de contas, o senhor diz já que está tudo na imprensa.
Só que a própria imprensa aponta algumas inconsistências nesse material, valores considerados fora do padrão,
nas etapas realizadas lá nos Estados Unidos.
A informação de que só uma das cinco etapas de produção foi feita aqui no Brasil.
E a alegação de que a produtora gastou mais do que recebeu, sem uma comprovação independente.
Eu vou perguntar de uma forma definitiva se o senhor ou a produtora vão apresentar o contrato,
ou novos documentos, ou números auditados, ou se o público vai ficar com aquilo que a imprensa já descobriu até agora,
para formar a sua opinião.
Bom, de forma definitiva, não tem absolutamente nada de errado em um filho buscar um financiamento,
um patrocínio privado para uma empresa privada, sem nada.
Zero, zero, zero, zero de dinheiro público.
Não fui buscar a Lei Rouanet.
E a obra está pronta.
Muito em breve, se Deus quiser, todos poderão ver.
Essa grande obra de arte, essa grande produção cinematográfica,
uma homenagem ao presidente Bolsonaro, alguém que quase deu a sua vida,
quase perdeu a sua vida para defender o seu próprio país.
A produtora fez a prestação de contas, inclusive para a justiça, que não viu absolutamente nada de errado.
A perícia foi feita e constatou que não tem nada de dinheiro público e nada de ilegal.
Agora eu estou muito tranquilo com relação a isso e eu quero, na verdade,
que quem deva explicações, dê explicações, que é o atual governo.
Porque uma coisa, Mariana, é a relação privada para esse filme, esse patrocínio.
Sem contrapartida de absolutamente nada.
Foi em 2025 que começou o patrocínio, portanto, o presidente não era o Bolsonaro.
Não tinha como o senador da República buscar algo que pudesse, enfim, ser dado em troca.
Então, absolutamente nada de errado.
É muito diferente do que fez o atual governo.
Aí sim que o Lula deve explicações, porque a gente não sabe até hoje, Mariana,
se ele é o patrocinador, se ele é o conselheiro, se ele é um sócio do Banco Master.
O próprio Lula, o próprio presidente da República, ele fez uma reunião prometendo para os representantes do Banco Master
que podiam esperar um pouquinho, porque o presidente do Banco Central ia ser trocado,
então o governo teria uma forma de ajudá-lo a resolver os seus problemas no Banco Master.
E quanto mais o tempo passa, mais todos veem que, com relação ao filme do Bolsonaro, não tem nada de errado.
Com relação à sua relação com o governo Lula, com o Jacques Wagner, com o Rui Costa, com o Guido Mantega, com o Lewandowski,
toda aquela galera que encerca ali o núcleo duro do Lula, incluindo o seu filho, todos ali têm muito a explicar.
O senhor, em outubro de 2025, sugeriu que os Estados Unidos atacassem embarcações na Bahia de Guanabara,
dentro do território brasileiro.
Isso não é um convite a uma ação militar estrangeira em solo nacional?
Não, de forma alguma. Importante a sua pergunta para esclarecer, porque foi naquele momento,
todos se lembram daquelas imagens do governo americano bombardeando navios de narcoterroristas
que saíam com grandes quantidades de drogas da Venezuela.
Eu fiz uma analogia, não pedi bombardeio de nada, eu só disse que, infelizmente, no Rio de Janeiro,
grande parte das drogas que abastecem os narcoterroristas do Rio de Janeiro também chegam de barco.
Portanto, eu, como presidente da República, quero me comprometer aqui,
porque quem tem que resolver os nossos problemas, Mariana, somos nós.
Então, Exército, Marinha, Aeronáutica, com o seu poder de polícia que tem,
vão ajudar as forças estaduais a combaterem os narcoterroristas aqui no Brasil.
E uma das primeiras coisas que eu vou fazer enquanto presidente da República
é declarar Comando Vermelho, PCC, milícias, como organizações terroristas.
Vocês se preparem, porque a partir do ano que vem, vocês verão um presidente da República
que vai lutar com tudo que tiver ao seu alcance para libertar o povo brasileiro
das garras e das maldades, desse governo paralelo, desse medo coletivo
que vocês tentam impor a mais de 50 milhões de brasileiros
que moram em áreas que hoje são dominadas por esses narcoterroristas.
Com participação dos Estados Unidos?
Como é que funciona? Não tem participação dos Estados Unidos,
não tem interferência dos Estados Unidos, não vai chegar alguém aqui e pegar
o presidente da República, o ministro e vai tirar do Brasil e vai levar para os Estados.
Não tem nada disso.
O que acontece é o que sempre houve, Mariana.
São acordos de cooperação na parte de inteligência, na parte de recursos humanos,
na parte de troca de informações.
Porque, veja bem, como é que um PCC está lavando dinheiro?
Ele lava dinheiro no comércio aqui e daqui a pouco o dinheiro sai do Brasil.
Como é que você vai atrás de quem está recebendo esse dinheiro fora do Brasil?
Fazendo acordos com outros países.
Então, comigo, o Brasil fará parte de uma coisa chamada que é o Escudo das Américas.
Onde países da América Latina, da América Central e também da América do Norte
se unem para combater o narcotráfico, para combater o tráfico internacional
de drogas e de armas e para asfixiar financeiramente essas organizações narcoterroristas.
O seu plano de governo fala em uma escola que ensina, não que doutrina.
Quais são os conteúdos que o senhor classifica como doutrinação?
E o senhor pretende reduzir o investimento obrigatório em educação,
que hoje tem 5,5% do PIB?
Mariana, a gente tem que melhorar a qualidade do investimento na educação.
Hoje, infelizmente, eu também tenho filhas pequenas.
Eu não quero que as minhas filhas de 14 e de 12 anos de idade vão para o colégio
e sejam ensinados para uma ideologia de esquerda ou para bacharias,
como a gente vê comumente acontecer em algumas escolas públicas do Brasil.
Eu quero que as minhas filhas aprendam português, matemática, outras línguas, espanhol e inglês.
Elas tenham noção de uma economia básica, matemática financeira para organizarem as suas vidas.
Eu quero que as minhas filhas aprendam empreendedorismo dentro de sala de aula.
Então, eu quero que as futuras gerações, os jovens que estão me assistindo,
como eu também estou oferecendo um programa Minha Primeira Empresa,
eles tenham a expectativa de algum dia na vida, quem sabe, serem um Elon Musk
e não serem o dono da boca de fumo da sua rua,
como infelizmente acontece hoje em muitas comunidades que são dominadas por esses marginais.
O que o senhor tiraria da grade curricular das escolas públicas?
Eu acho que a gente tem que começar mudando, como eu falei, empreendedorismo, matemática financeira.
Eu sou de uma época, acho que não é a sua, que você certamente é muito mais nova do que eu,
que era educação moral e cívica.
Quando a gente na escola aprendia a questionar, liam a matéria, dava uma opinião.
Então, incentivar os alunos a terem opinião, não impor uma opinião,
que é a opinião do professor, ao aluno.
Eu não quero a minha filha frequentando dentro de sala de aula, ou no colégio dela,
ou num shopping, que ela esteja no banheiro feminino,
e daqui a pouco entra uma pessoa que se sente mulher no banheiro junto com a minha filha.
E isso é ensinado dentro de sala de aula.
Então, a gente tem que encarar de frente, sim, porque quem tem que ter autonomia sobre os seus filhos são os pais.
Educação se aprende em casa.
No colégio, as gerações têm que ir para aprender e se prepararem para a vida,
não para serem manipuladas, doutrinadas, como infelizmente acontece hoje.
E hoje eu quero também investir muito, Mariana, na parte do ensino técnico e profissionalizante.
Os nossos jovens têm que aprender tecnologia, têm que aprender inteligência artificial.
O mundo hoje tem um grande boom de data centers que eu vou atrair aqui para o Brasil.
Vamos precisar de mão de obra qualificada para trabalhar nessa área.
Ontem foi o dia dos gamers, uma homenagem aqui, um parabéns a todos os gamers do Brasil.
Muitos jovens que podem trabalhar com desenvolvimento de gamers, enfim.
Tem uma infinidade de profissões do futuro que hoje as crianças não têm noção de como é que elas vão trabalhar com isso,
que não é ensinado dentro de sala de aula, então elas não estão preparadas para quando acabarem o ensino,
elas poderem trabalhar.
Então, na minha gestão, você, jovem que está me assistindo, não vai ter só apenas um diploma pendurado na sua parede.
Você vai ter o seu diploma e você vai ter a qualificação para conseguir ter o emprego que pague bem
ou a sua própria empresa e assim você levar dignidade para a sua família.
O senhor mencionou data centers nos Estados Unidos, as comunidades estão fazendo várias denúncias
de que a implementação desses data centers estão acabando com a água, porque eles consomem muita água do lençol freático.
O que o senhor faria para evitar um problema ambiental?
Olha, e a solução técnica para o resfriamento dos data centers, tem vários que são próximos à região litorânea.
Então, a própria água do mar pode ser usada para isso.
Já vi plataforma, alguns data centers que são construídos perto de plataforma de petróleo.
Esse detalhe técnico, como é que faz o arrefecimento, eu tenho certeza que se for um projeto bem feito,
a própria água pode ser reutilizada.
Ela resfria o data center e daqui a pouco ela pode ser reutilizada para continuar resfriando o data center.
Mas o importante é que hoje o Brasil, ele cria um ambiente hostil à atratividade desse tipo de investimento.
São dezenas de bilhões de reais que o Brasil está perdendo de oportunidade.
Isso gera muito emprego dentro do Brasil no momento da construção desses empreendimentos,
a manutenção deles, todo o conteúdo que é utilizado ali para ensinar o MAIA.
É um constante ensinamento daquela máquina para que seja utilizada em benefício,
para a utilidade de algum setor, na vida de cada um.
E hoje o Brasil tem uma taxa de 25% para quem quiser trazer os data centers para dentro do Brasil.
Enquanto outros países do mundo essa taxa é zero, inclusive cria-se benefícios para atrair esses empreendimentos para os países.
O Brasil está perdendo uma grande janela de oportunidade, mais uma vez, com o atual governo,
que não tem a capacidade de compreender.
O Brasil tem tudo aqui que podia ser um grande player, um grande agente atrativo desse tipo de investimento,
que vai trazer muitas oportunidades de trabalho, emprego e renda no nosso país.
Falando sobre emprego aqui no nosso país, a escala 6x1, que a proposta está no Congresso,
e tem apoio de 70% da população.
Claro que o setor produtivo diz que o fim da escala 6x1 traria uma série de problemas,
poderia encarecer as contratações, prejudicar as pequenas empresas e reduzir as vagas.
Como é que o senhor avalia? O senhor é a favor ou é contra essa mudança?
E se essa votação acontecer no Senado agora em setembro, como é que o senhor vai votar?
Mariana, a gente vai defender a liberdade de você, trabalhador, escolher qual é a sua escala de trabalho.
Qual é a proposta alternativa que é muito melhor do que essa daí que o atual governo está propondo?
Na véspera da eleição, muita gente acreditando que vai ser uma coisa que vai resolver a vida.
Não vai. É a liberdade de você, vai ter todos os seus direitos trabalhistas garantidos,
como estão na Constituição Federal, mas vai trabalhar quantas horas você quiser.
Você vai montar a sua escala de trabalho.
O senhor, na sua campanha, promete cortar impostos.
Ao mesmo tempo, também disse que vai criar 500 mil vagas no sistema prisional.
Como é que o senhor paga as duas coisas sem estourar o orçamento, sem aumentar a dívida pública?
Olha, o ajuste fiscal no Brasil é a coisa mais fundamental que precisa ser feita.
Porque você que está devendo, por exemplo, o juro da sua dívida, que corrige a sua dívida, não está alto pra caramba?
É porque ele é indexado, ele sobe conforme o juro oficial do governo subir.
Então, o seu atual governo, Mariana, ele gasta demais? Gasta muito.
Aí, o que ele faz? Aumenta a carga tributária, toma ali imposto no seu bolso para arrecadar ainda mais.
E, ao invés dele equilibrar as contas, ele gasta ainda mais.
Consequência, taxa selic, a taxa social, lá na estratosfera, lá na Lua, 14%, a maior juro real do mundo.
A sua dívida é corrigida, puxada, por esse índice.
A parcela do financiamento que você pegou, do empréstimo que você tomou, ela fica a cada dia maior.
Você paga e a dívida não se encerra nunca, é uma bola de neve crescente.
A culpa não é sua, a culpa é desse governo.
Como é que eu vou resolver isso? Equilibrando as contas, cortando gastos, é tesouraço na burocracia, é tesouraço nos impostos, é tesouraço em mais de mil atos normativos que a minha equipe econômica já está preparando para fazer logo no primeiro dia de governo, para facilitar a vida de quem quer empreender.
Eu vou ter, Mariana, uma espécie de governança digital com inteligência artificial.
Vamos ter um data center soberano para o Brasil.
De seis meses a um ano, eu consigo ter essa inteligência artificial controlando cada centavo de dinheiro público.
Desde a água que o governo compra, até as grandes licitações, passando pelo controle das emendas parlamentares, passando pelas nomeações das pessoas que vão trabalhar no governo.
Tudo isso vai ser transparente, digital e em tempo real. Com isso, eu vou economizar algumas dezenas de bilhões.
E equilibrando as contas, já que eu também vou buscar novas receitas, para que aumente a receita sem aumentar o imposto e vou reduzir as despesas,
cada um ponto, Mariana, que eu consiga reduzir.
A taxa de juros oficial desse governo significa 90 bilhões de reais que eu abro no orçamento,
para poder pagar uma parte da dívida, investir em infraestrutura e fazer o social, por exemplo,
algum mecanismo que possa ser utilizado para reduzir a sua taxa de juros, para que você consiga pagar a sua dívida.
O senhor promete melhorar o atendimento do SUS, ampliar o médico da família, digitalizar o sistema
e ainda pagar clínicas e hospitais particulares para ajudar a reduzir as filas.
Só que tudo isso também custa dinheiro e é dinheiro público todo ano, de onde viria a verba.
Mariana, o orçamento para a saúde pública federal é da casa dos 250 bilhões de reais.
O que a gente está oferecendo? É realmente trazer a tecnologia para o SUS.
Tanto é que eu escolhi aqui, para ser o nosso ministro da saúde, alguém que estava presidente dos principais hospitais particulares do Brasil,
que é o doutor Cláudio Lothenberg, porque eu quero implementar no SUS o padrão Einstein de atendimento.
Eu quero levar para a rede pública, para você que usa o SUS, o mesmo tratamento e a mesma metodologia, a mesma tecnologia,
o mesmo atendimento de qualidade que as pessoas ricas têm, aquelas que procuram, por exemplo, a rede Einstein.
Então, estou trazendo um importante nome para poder fazer essa organização e basicamente,
vai ser um investimento muito alto em tecnologia, de novo, e em inteligência artificial.
Nós vamos buscar dentro desses quatro anos, conectar todos os sistemas de saúde dos municípios, dos estados e da União,
só para ficar num exemplo bastante prático.
Você, por exemplo, mora numa cidade aí no Rio de Janeiro, você mora em Belforrocho, por exemplo.
Aí você está esperando para fazer uma cirurgia de catarata e nesse hospital municipal em Belforrocho não tem vaga,
mas de repente tem vaga em Mesquita do lado.
Esse sistema é na palma da sua mão, que nós vamos oferecer uma plataforma do governo, no seu celular,
para que você saiba aonde é que tem a vaga para você fazer a cirurgia mais rápida.
E o mesmo raciocínio, Mariana, vai ser para as cirurgias eletivas, as emergências.
Você vai saber aonde é que tem uma unidade de saúde mais próxima de você,
aonde não tem fila ou onde tem menos fila, para você levar o seu filho na hora que ele estiver com febre,
com diarreia, quebrar um braço, você possa levar ele mais rapidamente para que ele seja bem cuidado
numa unidade básica de saúde.
Vamos criar, então, esse protocolo eletrônico unificado em todo o Brasil.
É que é algo que eu acho que é plenamente possível se nós tivermos pessoas competentes,
como um diretor do hospital Albert Einstein,
querendo implementar essa mesma tecnologia, essa mesma metodologia para todo o sistema público de saúde.
O senhor promete indulto ao ex-presidente Jair Bolsonaro, seu pai,
que foi condenado por tentativa de golpe de Estado.
Ele seria ministro do seu governo? Teria algum papel no seu governo?
Olha, eu tenho o privilégio de ter dentro de casa um melhor quadro que o Brasil possa ter na política.
Alguém que foi presidente da República, um cara competente, um patriota, honesto.
Então, ele vai ser sempre, Mariana, o meu conselheiro.
E eu não tenho promessa, não.
Eu vou honrar todas as pessoas que foram perseguidas no 8 de janeiro.
O presidente Bolsonaro foi julgado pelos seus inimigos, gente.
Já pensou? Você que está me assistindo.
Se você fosse para um julgamento e quem fosse julgar fosse o seu inimigo,
você acha que qual seria o final desse julgamento?
Seria um processo que já começaria você sabendo qual é o resultado final.
E foi assim que o presidente Bolsonaro.
Ele foi julgado pelo Fábio Dino, por exemplo, que é um inimigo declarado dele.
Disse que o Bolsonaro é o demônio na Terra.
Ele foi julgado pelo Zanin, Mariana, que até ontem era advogado do Lula.
E pelo Alexandre de Moraes, que todo mundo sabe que é um inimigo declarado de Bolsonaro.
Então, foi uma grande farsa a que não apenas o presidente Bolsonaro foi submetido,
mas todos esses 8 de janeiro.
Então, vou trabalhar assim.
Logo após a Mariana anunciar daquela bancada aqui da Record,
que o próximo presidente eleito do Brasil em 2026 é Flávio Bolsonaro,
a gente vai trabalhar no Congresso para que aconteça a anistia.
E caso não dê tempo de acontecer, nós vamos indutar, sim, essas pessoas.
E lembrando que o próximo presidente da República indica 4 ministros do Supremo Tribunal Federal.
E eu vou indicar homens e mulheres que sejam comprometidos em serem contra o aborto,
em serem contra as drogas e que não usem a caneta para fazer injustiça com ninguém.
Qual é o perfil principal, é esse, dos ministros que o senhor pretende indicar?
É quase metade da corte, né?
São 4... tem uma vaga que está em aberto, que é a do Messias, que não foi preenchida.
E tem mais três que ao longo do próximo mandato, o próximo presidente da República,
no caso Flávio Bolsonaro, terá oportunidade de indicar.
Caso seja eleito?
Não, eu indico o nome agora e já começo a tomar uma saraivada de matérias do jornal,
sem parar, mas no momento certo, obviamente.
Como eu disse, o perfil vai ser esse, homens e mulheres que sejam de verdade patriotas
e que pensem em trazer segurança jurídica de volta e resgatar a credibilidade do Supremo.
O senhor mencionou que, claro, o seu pai participaria de um eventual governo seu,
e o senhor...
Eu não disse isso, mas não como ministro, não sei, nunca conversei com ele se ele quer,
se ele teria interesse nisso, não sei.
Como conselheiro, pelo menos.
Não, mas obviamente, até hoje eu ouço o presidente Bolsonaro,
em cada passo que eu dou na minha vida, eu penso nele todos os segundos nessa campanha,
como eu gostaria que ele estivesse nas ruas, junto comigo, ou melhor,
como ele deveria, inclusive, ter habilitado para concorrer à presidência da República,
tendo em vista a perseguição e passou e se manta essa missão que eu estou cumprindo com toda a vida.
Se o ex-presidente Bolsonaro quiser participar do governo, ser um ministro, ele será?
Mas aí vai depender da vontade dele.
Se o senhor for eleito, qual será a primeira medida que o senhor vai tomar?
O senhor mencionou um ajuste fiscal duro, vai ser logo no primeiro ano?
O que eu vou fazer é declarar Comando Vermelho, PCC e milícias como organizações terroristas.
Eu vou ser incansável, Mariana, e a partir de janeiro do ano que vem,
eu vou declarar guerra a esses narcoterroristas,
porque eu vou libertar o Brasil dessa chaga, desse câncer, dessa doença chamada impunidade.
Esses caras, eles é que têm que ter medo de andar na rua, não você, cidadão, trabalhador e trabalhadora.
Eu vou defender você.
Candidato, muito obrigada pela sua entrevista.
Eu que agradeço.
E nas próximas semanas, o Domingo Espetacular segue com as entrevistas dos principais candidatos à presidência da República,
Ronaldo Caiado e Romeu Zema.
E ainda nesta edição, você vai ficar sabendo como foi o dia deles em campanha pelo Brasil.
Eu vou fazer uma cerra a segunda parte.